c'est dans l'actuelle vous écoutez sud
radio il est 7 heures 10 je le disais il
ya quelques jours emmanuel macron
annonce que les pourboires payer par
carte bancaire seront sans charge pour
les employeurs sans impôt pour les
salariés réforme porté à l'assemblée
nationale par notre invité bonjour à
vous jean noël barrot au genre vous êtes
député modem des yvelines vice président
de la commission des finances c'est vous
qui avez eu cette idée à l'origine vous
l'aviez publiée dans les échos le
président la reprise vous déposer un
amendement dans le projet de loi de
finances si jamais ça passe à partir de
quand entrera en vigueur mais écoutez
d'abord rappeler un élément de contexte
nous avons perdu l'habitude de donner un
pourboire 1 français sur 3 déclarent ne
plus en données faute d'avoir de
l'argent liquide en poche les pièces
jaunes est ce que l'on constate en
parallèle c'est qu'avec la reprise avec
la réouverture des restaurants et bien
les hôtels les cafés les restaurants de
plus en plus de mal à trouver des
serveurs et du personnel 160 mille
postes à pourvoir l'été donc d'un côté
il ya le problème du pouvoir d'achat des
serveurs et de l'autre les français qui
laissait moins de pourboire donc du coup
vous populariser cette idée là il
récompense des manuels macro est une
excellente nouvelle et c'est du gagnant
gagnant parce que ça va permettre en
relançant le pourboire en reprenant
l'habitude du pourboire et bien
d'apporter un complément de rémunération
aux serveurs mais ça ne coûte rien à
l'employeur puisque c'est une cellule
c'est le consommateur c'est le client
troyen a porté ce complément et ça ne
coûte rien aux finances publiques
puisque jusqu'à présent bien il y avait
le pouvoir c'est vrai marché le pourvoi
marché mais en plus ils étaient en
pièces du coup c'est à partir de quand
si le si les délais sont tenus vous
déposé cet amendement au projet de loi
de finances ça sera à partir du 1er
janvier puisque quand on prépare un
budget à l'assemblée nationale ça
commence le 1er janvier de l'année
suivante comment ça va marcher moi je
paye 15 euros par exemple au lieu de 13
euros 40 ans carte bancaire ou un
restaurant la différence elle ira
directement dans la poche du serveur ou
écouter va se mettre en place un certain
nombre de solutions soit sur le terminal
de paiement c'est-à-dire sur la machine
à carte soit à travers des qr codes dont
on a pris l'habitude ces derniers
n'auraient même beaucoup et ça permettra
effectivement de séparer le flux qui
correspond à l'addition du flux qui
correspond aux pour bois et avec cet
élément de défiscalisation qu'a annoncé
le président de la république eh ben il
n'y aura plus de différence entre le
liquide et le pourboire numérique et ça
ira tout seul et on reprendra ainsi nos
habitudes puisque deux français sur
trois disent qu'ils seraient prêts à
l'espé hier pour bois si le pourboire et
et numérique dont il nous manque
toujours des pièces dans notre poche
vous disiez que de moins en moins de
français avaient tendance à laisser un
pourboire six mois j'étais par exemple
je fais un serveur dans un bar à
montpellier en moyenne le pourboire
aujourd'hui ça peut représenter quelle
part de mon revenu c'est difficile à
estimer puisqu'aujourd'hui il ya de
moins en moins de pourboire et qu'en
parallèle ses pourboires ne sont pas
toujours déclarées mais selon les
établissements ça peut représenter une
part significative de la rémunération
est donc un vrai coup de pouce pour les
salariés de ce secteur où quand vous
allez au bar ou alors en terrasse vous
voulez c'est toujours un pouvoir bien
non pas toujours et c'est ce dont je me
suis aperçu en réfléchissant à ce succès
vous avez une idée justement j'ai pas
assez de pièces donc il faut que je
fasse part car exactement et il faut
qu'on puisse avoir des solutions simples
et il faut que sur le plan fiscal il ya
une incitation forte fait ça et donc du
coup il n'y aura plus d'impôts il n'y
aura plus de charges comment ils ont
accueilli cette nouvelle les
professionnels pas c'est évidemment une
idée que nous avons eu l'occasion de
travailler avec les professionnels du
secteur mentionné du de laquelle nous
sommes dans contact en lien avec le
gouvernement pour définir exactement la
manière dont ça va entrer dans le code
général des impôts mais globalement il
ya un accueil qui est très favorable
est-ce qu'il ya je pense une envie
collective qu'on reprenne cette bonne
habitude du pourboire c'est ça la
politesse justement du client merci
beaucoup jean noël barrot député modem
des yvelines vice président de la
commission des finances je vous souhaite
un bon petit déjeuner vous laisser un
pourboire j'espère vous avez des pièces
en secret merci à vous et merci à vous
d'être intervenu sur sud radio dans le
grand matin week-end rester avec